à log et ça va bientôt faire un an que
le meurtre de génique delcourt avait
lieu un meurtre soit dit en passant qui
n'a jamais été élucidé
on va parler de l'enquète dans un
instant mais d'abord françois cormier
la ville de longueuil veut parler ses
citoyens demandent l'avis des citoyens
en fait pour tenter de rendre plus
sécuritaire les lieux publics c'était
arrivé ça sur une piste cyclable près du
boulevard chambaud
oui en fait la piste cyclable sur
laquelle on se trouve en ce moment
patrice et la mairesse de longueuil
caroline st-hilaire nous expliquer qu'à
la chute donc de ce meurtre en octobre
l'année dernière il y avait eu que
plusieurs citoyens il ya eu plusieurs
citoyens qui ont soulevé qui ont signalé
des uns qu'ils étaient inquiets par
rapport à la sécurité ici à la ville de
longueuil nom parmi les mesures qui sont
prises aujourd'hui à cette consultation
finalement les citoyens de longueuil qui
sont appelés à aller sur le site
internet de la ville et à inscrire il ya
une espèce de cartes interactives c'est
très facile d'y accéder une carte
interactive vous cliquez sur l'endroit
où vous juger qu'il ya un problème et
vous inscrivez décrivez de quoi de quoi
il s'agit en fait comme problème est là
il ya quelqu'un de la ville finalement
qu'il veut qui va s'occuper de
répertorier tous les commentaires qui a
été fait et on va tenter
on va tenter d'y donner suite ça se
passera donc au cours des trois
prochaines semaines ça commençait ce
matin la ville qui n'exclut pas de
garder ce site internet là pour pour la
chute parce que c'est très très
interactif finalement on garde un
contact assez facile avec les citoyens
on nous demande aussi à l'âme à la
mairesse si elle rendrait publiques les
données qui seront que qui seront
collectées à partir de ceux de ce site
internet
voici sa réponse suivi de quelques
citoyens de longueuil à qui on a demandé
si leur ville était sécuritaire selon
lui on voudrait pas non plus créer un
sentiment de panique des voix si ce
secteur là les gens se sentent
pas en sécurité le but ce n'est pas ça
le but c'est au contraire d'augmenter la
sécurité
on verra ce qu'on va rendre public le
plan d'action je pense votre divulgué
beaucoup d'informations mais on vers
paul la carte de longueuil
avec les points rouges gars je me
promène ici puis je m'en prends ma
sécurité personnelle que chic à des
quartiers ne peut plus problématique du
métro longueuil jusqu'à jusqu'au parc
j'ai absolument pas de difficultés j'ai
des enfants tout le monde se promène en
vélo ou à pied à la course
oui télé oui je pourrais poser cette
possibilité mais j'avais un terrier
terrible mais voilà c'est bien entendu
citoyen l'a dit il faut pas non plus
exagérer quand même
l' enquête sur la mort de genève
dalcourt piétine la ce que ça se
poursuit oui mais piétine à nos yeux
patrice mais visiblement pas aux yeux du
service de police de la ville de
longueuil qui nous dit aujourd'hui que
l'enquêtre progresse et qu'elle est
toujours prioritaire sans évidemment
donner de détails
par contre on refuse de commenter
directement cette initiative de la ville
vous avez entendu donc la mairesse
st-hilaire parler de ses inquiétudes
entre autres des services policiers de
dévoiler les endroits où cette époque
sécuritaire d'aller donc voilà la police
qui nous dit en bref que l' enquête
progresse on verra bien quand on aura
des résultats très bien merci un
françois morvan